[Musik]
ich habe mode made katastrophen das
wegen wirtschaftsverbrechen und güter
ins in großen mengen durch den britisch
ziehen sie schreibt also von natürlich
ganz viel geld verloren und im
kreislichen konkursmasse verlaufen und
das furchtbare ist einmal weiter google
sag ich mal dann sieht man ja dass diese
leute weiter waren
ich danke den stars ruf summiert das
sind dass der goldrichtig von einer
milliarde
es wird einfach kein ende nehmen wenn
nicht jetzt irgendwas passiert
[Musik]
santo domingo eine hinterhof disco der
luzerner raphael per hunger tritt an dem
härtesten kampfsport nm mixed martial
arts deutsch gemischte kampfkünste
das geht von boxen zum kick boxen karate
ringen gtc oder jude es ist das jahr
2001 raphael personal lebt in florida
seinen lebensunterhalt verdiente als
kampfsportlehrer in seinem eigenen klub
und als fluglehrer die kämpfe bestreitet
er nebenbei dies ist einer seiner
letzten kämpfer perlinger sie zurück in
die schweiz
[Musik]
was er damals nicht geahnt hat die
härtesten schläge in seinem leben stehen
ihm erst noch bevor
[Musik]
raphael per hunger beginnt in luzern als
schwinger und ringer per hunger bernd
beharrlich neue kampfsporttechniken er
ist erfolgreich holt sich nationale und
internationale titel seit 2005 ist
rafael per hunger zurück in der schweiz
er betreibt drei kampfsportschulen und
er hat einen traum mixed martial arts
europaweit einzuführen als
geschäftsmodell nach amerikanischem
vorbild
ich kann eigentlich der ganze aufbau der
kampfsportart in den usa beobachtet paar
eigene kampf clubkarte das ist eishockey
aber nicht um im la belle machen und
dann nicht als krähe das in europa
einfach reise visa loch ist das ist noch
nicht geht und das data machen kann ist
und ich habe das einwählen aufbauen in
europa also der kampfsport generell aber
ist spezifisch dass wir machen kein
blick mehr die der usa diese stelle war
also ich wohne in den usa verkauft und
haben mit dem erlös vor der wohnung kann
ich mir schon den usa weil so dtb liga
ist das bio ist habe ich mir die ganze
material gekauft es sind schluss 14 20
fuß container importiert hat schweiz das
heißt die klubs ganze konzepte schalten
sie das ist ein großes projekt sportler
perlinger merkt er braucht die hilfe
eines finanz fachmannes
im dezember 2005 betritt ein mann namens
jürgen käfer die kampfsportschule
irgendwer verbaut wird er kenne sich aus
dem kampfsport und bei der finanzierung
solcher projekte
jetzt muss er hält sich fantastisch
verkauft kaffee und natürlich auch so
wenn ein obwohl günstigstes ihr kollege
macht um verbündete wie klaut man kennt
umbau der hund krank gemacht das ist
eine zelle angegangen aber anfangen
hätte das wirklich macht sie forciert
oder und das hat funktioniert ich an
etwas glaubt will
so sehe sehr glaubwürdig was da auf
empfehlungen diesmal nicht erkennen ist
dass der körper schon massive blutspur
hinterlassen der schweiz und deutschland
und dass der käufer eigentlich kategorie
nitot finanzierungsexperte gold sondern
viel eher kategorie finanzschwindler
[Musik]
die zukunft gegeben tatsächlich jürgen
käfers vergangenheit ist dubios mitte
der 90er jahre verspricht er an
massenveranstaltungen dem schnellen
reichtum die firma fca wir menschen per
fernseher den zugang zum internet
ermöglichen
doch fca ist ein schneeballsystem
reich werden dabei wenn überhaupt nur
die befinde
[Musik]
nach diesem tag ja wird alles anders
sein
machen sie mal als ob sei es immer so
als ob es für uns keine begrenzung gibt
als ob es keine begrenzung gibt für spaß
für geld verdienen und für neue dinge
schaffen
ebenfalls in den 90ern organisiert käfer
psychologisch angehauchte wohlfühl und
manager seminare wie stark bremst sich
dein ego
die hilfe eines mentaltrainers immer
wieder tauchte im fernsehen auf zum
beispiel als mentaltrainer der deutschen
skispringer nationalmannschaft jürgen
käfer trainiert normalerweise manager
jetzt trainiert er skispringer und deren
trainer der mentaltrainer hilft den
sportlern in ihrer neuen rolle zurecht
zu kommen
es geht um die den ganzheitlichen ansatz
thema ich bin erfolgreich aber wie kann
ich ein erfolg halten den erfolgsdruck
mit dem erfolgsdruck umzugehen
käfer kreiert neue geschäftsideen und
gründe zwielichtige firmen hunderte
verlieren geld jürgen käfer bewegt sich
am rande der legalität
[Musik]
diese vergangenheit des finanziers
kannte rafael bungert nicht von krise
oder ex-banker absoluter profi und dass
er vermittelt das hätte der geheimen der
käufer cvc das ist wasser auf das ist
offensichtlich und das klingt gut
zuerst lässt jürgen käfer die firma max
entertainment gründen
er stellt einen businessplan macht sich
zum chef und startet seine show
schlagen zu wenn du musst
er schlage nicht
wenn du nicht muss
die lage nicht
wenn die nicht kannst
und wenn du nicht stolz
[Musik]
jürgen käfer ceo von nexenta tainment
[Applaus]
der anerkannte erfolgstrainer und
diplomierte sporttrainer mit 20 jahren
erfahrung im karate leistungssport ist
bei der max entertainment group
verantwortlich für strategie
organisation marketing und finanzen
das video zeigt das vermeintliche
potenzial von max entertainment dazu
gehören wettbüros an großveranstaltungen
und trainings clubs für fitness fans die
max james für kampfsport begeisterte
jeden alters
parallel sollen sportartikel verkauf und
merchandising die firmenkasse füllen
eine lukrative geschäftsidee nach
amerikanischen vorbild
die werbung ist teil der inszenierung
max entertainment ist eine scheinfirma
sie soll gar nie operativ tätig werden
doch das bis nur jürgen käfer und
vielleicht seine frau karin
[Musik]
käfer lässt tausende abzudrucken
aktionäre soll das start up unternehmen
finanzieren
der aktienverkauf soll binnen eines
halben jahres 30 millionen franken
einnahmen bringen
für den aktienhandel engagiert käfer
zwei dutzend telefonverkäufer sie
arbeiten auf provision sieht
entsprechend unter druck
die truppe ist käfers geldmaschine die
aktienverkäufe suchen investoren zuerst
den umfeld interessierter kampfsportler
über vereine und verbände gelangen sie
an adressen oliver frey ist begeisterter
sportler
aber oliver frey ist auch buchhalter und
investiert nur in ein geschäft das er
versteht frei kennt das potenzial
solcher organisationen aus den usa und
die werbung beeindruckt ihn ich es an
die conti sportfans und das hat
natürlich scheibe zitiert das ist quasi
da ich es gesehen
das riesige bild und der tiere einfach
wärme die stiege
frey investiert 5000 franken die
aktienverkäufe drängen zu mir
doch der familienvater will und kann
nicht mehr einschießen
doch zeigt die sich die verkäufe
abgespielt haben
die aktienkäufer raten zum schnellen
einstieg max entertainment sei noch
unbekannt
die aktie unterbewertet
[Musik]
helfen kann dabei gehirn ist feuer legen
erwarten wir dass wir wenn als schon
mitte juni im kurs haben 27 und us
dollar
[Musik]
und kündigen an den börsengang an
da wird erst mal richtig interessant mal
dann werden die leute die wie die
klubführung man da springen wir wirklich
um 45 106 prozent wo man sich nicht so
komisch sind in ganz normal bei bergen
aktionärs fallen leerer versprechungen
der anlage fachmann und der ehemalige
friedensrichter berg güttler kennt die
szene aus eigenen erfahrungen
er hatte mit finanzmitteln zu tun und
ihren tricks recherchiert dass hinaus
soll die maschine hat vor 2 uhr seminar
der börsen und dem heißt es kalt
verzwanzigfacht vertriebskraft und das
ist natürlich für mich klarer betrug
will es sich nicht möglich innerhalb von
nur annähernd fertig geworden
natürlich unsere in einem monat oder
anderen halb auf der
aktionärsversammlung und da will ich
ihnen dann kräftig geschüttelt und mit
ihnen die augen schauen so wie es sich
gehört
weil das ist normalerweise nicht unsere
absicht übers telefon irgendwelche
sachen zu agieren
die entscheiden natürlich selber diesen
entscheidung fertigten den man von
menschen menschenrechtler wie gesagt wir
haben wir haben wir haben doch beide
einholen oder kommt doch auch der
comeback haben wir bei ihm weil ich
spüre schon nicht wie ich würde und
regenschauer ein jeder andere
das sind foto str sie lügt sondern das
sind die grundqualität wo wahrscheinlich
schon relativ stark ausgebaut wurde es
im vorher über kosten callcenter szene
und wonach die entsprechende einfach
geschliffen wurde sind also mehr zeit
zum beispiel der arteria güte das weiß
ich noch ganz genau und mädels geschäft
kletterte mirja pütz seit es pressiert
sofort auf bank nämlich jene das grab
faxe die zahlungsbestätigung und den
dass man es unbedingt sein neuester
tages sport will ich noch mal vom
letzten mal will ich jetzt noch mal
deutlich diese platzierung von diesem
kleinen paket anbieten dafür das
geschäft heute hier und jetzt machen
dazu sagen okay die reservieren diese
anteile dann kann ich zu diesem preis
keiner mehr nehmen
aber was wollen wir denn da warten sehr
einer erfolgsgeschichte muss man von
anfang an der weiter
die geldmaschine läuft 20 verkäufer
telefonieren von früh morgens bis in die
nacht hunderte mögliche geldgeber
erhalten werbematerial
anleger investieren jeweils zwischen ein
paar tausend bis mehrere zehntausend
franken
schon in den ersten monaten spielt die
maschinerie 8 millionen franken in die
kasse doch meistens fließt das geld gar
nicht in die firma
[Musik]
gemerkt dass läuft zwar nicht so wenn
ich wollte aber ich wähle ich kann ich
so noch nicht stören und ich hatte
eigentlich in noch immer viel für juni
sollen einfach nie einen ganzen und sagt
ich hatte nie damit du aber das projekt
sie und ich glaube dass das läuft und
ich hatte einfach probiert erhalten das
beste nichts machen was er verpflichtet
ist
jürgen käfer hatte nie die absicht max
entertainment tatsächlich aufzubauen es
war ein grandios inszenierten schwindel
mit dem einzigen zweck aktien zu
verkaufen
die firma sollte gar nie operativ tätig
werden max war eine scheinfirma
accessoires oder mentaler das glaubt man
einer frau k und alles investiert wird
und der mit dem rapper nicht gerechnet
der verkauf der aktien brachte
schliesslich 40 bis 50 millionen franken
ein
das geld ist verschwunden hunderte
betrogene aktionäre erleiden
totalverlust
[Musik]
einer vor allem hat kassiert jürgen
käfer und der taucht unter
[Musik]
tocqueville millionen käfer reden
mehrmals bitten wir um ein interview
kefer hatte in den letzten jahren bei
diversen dubiosen firmen die hände im
spiel
vertrauenswürdige geschäftsadressen wie
schloss gronau in der nähe von zug
preußen seriosität vor
hier ist er nicht mehr die firmen muss
ihren jeweils ein scheinbar
gewinnträchtiges produkt in traffic
sollte die sendung einen neuartigen
internet service verkaufen
telefonverkäufer ködern aktionäre mit
übertriebenen renditeversprechen kiefer
hält sich stets im hintergrund
die firmen befinden sich oft in
derselben region
auffällige einfach das für die ganze
wirtschaft kriminalfall das tier sich im
sogenannten bermudadreieck abspiele das
bermudadreieck sind wesentlicher trüge
wird sich der polizist wo sks epizentrum
ist also betrügen
es gibt natürlich sehr viel rund um zell
und natürlich auch das ist el dorado für
audi wirtschaftskrimineller krank und
zog im kanton zug in vinnenberg startete
2004 ein gigantischer anlagen schwindel
mit der rauch losen zigarette nicstic
nicstic wein blanc nicstic kam nie auf
den markt
zuvor hatten a grade verkäufer
zehntausende aktien über diverse aspekte
firmen in der region verhökert
800 aktionäre verloren 200 millionen
franken
auch hinter diesem bluff steckten
deutsche ganoven michael berresheim
zieht seit 20 jahren anleger über den
tisch des heim stammt aus frankfurt hält
sich aber immer wieder in der schweiz
auf heinz piroth gilt als einer der
berüchtigsten beträge am deutschen
finanzmarkt auch pieroth geschäftet
immer wieder in der schweiz
betrüger pieroth ging raffiniert vor bei
nicstic missbrauchte er die homepage der
ubs und der cruze listet die ubs
einschätzungen über den wert einer aktie
auf buy nächstes steht 15 franken 15
franken waren maßlos übertrieben
der wert wurde manipuliert eine
treuhandfirma konnte den übrigen kurs
auf die homepage der ubs einspeisen und
wurde dafür von nächste bezahlt eine
täuschung mit folgen
wenn du bist so ein oft homepage
organischer der focus das deutsche reich
[Musik]
für die recherchen dieses films reiste
dog in den letzten vier jahren zu
dubiosen firmen in deutschland und in
der schweiz
die branche fühlte sich gestört mit droh
mails versuchte jemand die recherche zu
verhindern
[Musik]
die mails stammen aus dem dunstkreis von
nicstic längst wurden neue firmen
gegründet und bei gefahr wieder
geschlossen domizilierten der schweiz
manchmal mit ablegern in deutschland
oder den usa oft beteiligt wächst die
ganoven berresheim und piroth seit
letztem jahr sitzen die beiden in
untersuchungshaft in deutschland ihre
firmen keimlinge in der schweiz aber
wachsen weiter vor allem im kanton
schwyz steigt die zahl dubioser firmen
roland meier auf wirtschaftsdelikte
spezialisierter staatsanwalt im kanton
schwyz kämpft mit ungleichen spiessen de
lüt sind absolut exzellent geschulte
verkäufer sie benützt die modernste
kommunikationsmittel und france internet
geht eine unglaubliche möglichkeiten
sich an seriösen anstrich zka und
halbwahrheiten zu verbreiten was wo mir
demgegenüber zur verfügung steht ist
strafgesetzbuch unterstanden 107 risk
und kurz mal ist das alles nicht
[Musik]
open market television ist ein produkt
von maxtax wendler per sein
die internationale firma will ein
fernsehformat für unternehmen
produzieren
[Musik]
was aufwändig ausschaut ist eine weitere
attrappe zur tv firma gehört rothaus
domiziliert in den usa und zürich
auch in der rothaus steckt nicstic
schwindler berresheim während
staatsanwälte und konkursrichter über
seinen alten akten briten hat barca mit
einem anderen ganoven bereits eine neue
bosheit ausgeheckt jürgen käfer käfer
liefert ihm adressen bereits ab
kassierte aktionäre damit berresheim sie
ein zweites mal ausnehmen kann der
deutsche nutzt das schweizer briefkasten
system auch rothaus ist nur ein
briefkasten kran prinzip vor alten
friedhof der firma un-sitz gesellschaft
und verschachtelte imperial kann stück
über wahre berechtigte oder
transaktionen mit marotz natürlich der
behörde möglichst schwermachen
transaktionen nachts verfolgt das läuft
meine ich vor der schweiz über karibik
und tänzer oder über liechtenstein über
die befragten firmen viele wanderer oder
über acht die banken kurz die
transaktion über grenzen hinweg mit
verschiedenen gesellschaften die eine
natürliche und vor allem aber
verhinderte vor der rückverfolgt
verfolgt von den kapitalstrom ein mann
sieht seit 20 jahren leute über den
tisch und kassierte bei millionen 2
notorischen schurken kreieren laufend
scheinfirmen und hinterlassen hunderte
geprellte anleger
es geht insgesamt um einen schaden von
einer milliarde von
deshalb stoppt niemand die ganoven
zuständig ist neben den kantonalen
strafbehörden die eidgenössische
finanzmarktaufsicht finma werden soft
rock are meer das meer bewilligte
institute sind danke versicherte und
zitierte mir regelmäßig beaufsichtigen
und es geht aber positiv für andere
finanzdienstleister wo da die sind die
keine minute flächendeckend beobachtet
haben mir ressourcen ist das ist ja
nicht unser auftrag wir können nur
agieren weil mehr babys über können dass
allenfalls gegen finanznot gesetz
verstoßen werde und den werden aktiv auf
der suche nach jürgen käfer redet mit
ehemaligen mitarbeitern
sie habe miterlebt wie käfer mit seinen
geschäften im laufe der jahre viel sehr
viel geld erschwindelt hat
seinen besitz präsentiert käfer auf
facebook in die geschäfte verwickelt ist
meist seine frau karin
[Musik]
zum exquisiten lebensstil gehören teure
hobbys und ein stattlicher wagen park
trotzdem macht käfer dauernd schulden
sie wachsen zeitweise auf eine halbe
million franken
der deutsche sport vor allem bei den
schweizer steuern
[Musik]
regensburg in bayern
der geschäftsführer dieses motorrad
hauses investierte 150000 euro in max
entertainment das geld war langfristig
für die altersvorsorge gedacht die
investition in ein unternehmen das mit
kampfsport zu tun hat sheen sinnvoll
diese kämpfer wird es immer geben
diese kämpfe kommen aus allen herren
länder die sind immer da und da ist auch
immer begeisterung da die menschen
wollen das sehen
das war für mich das einzige thema wo
ich geld investieren wollte ihm nichts
anderes hätte ich es getan
[Musik]
als er angerufen wurde musste ihn der
verkäufer nicht groß überzeugen
jeder ließ sich auf die kundenliste
setzen die telefonverkäufer verdienen
kräftig mit in guten monaten kommen zwei
dutzend verkäufer auf 700000 franken
provisionen
das entspricht einem monatslohn pro
verkäufer von 29.000 kommen einige der
telefonverkäufer gehören zum festen
establishment der ganoven sie waren bei
früheren gaunereien beteiligt jürgen
käfer hat sie für max entertainment
übernommen der anfangszeit hat natürlich
käfer es geschafft mit sehr viel
hintergrund mit sehr viel verblendung
mit vision anreizen die leute über zu
holen da gab es einen moderator von mtv
den viele viele kannten
da gab es eine monstrum aufbauen gab es
brennt mails wir alles damit nach mein
name ist monate besonnen diesem page
wird kein charakter überstehen es war
einfach die pure verführung und es war
sehr sehr gut gemacht
zurück beim martial arts extremen und
wermers den straßen kampfsportler hinter
den kulissen marschall putin
unter dem präsidenten von den
messethemen super g hallo hallo was
erwartet die zuschauer wo aufkündige
fast sein martial arts extreme ja die
zuschauer können sich definitiv auf
hochmotivierte und sehr sehr ehrgeizige
kämpfer freuen
die natürlich mit herz leib und seele
und vollem einsatz hier alles zeigen
können was sie drauf haben
the selfish für die nächste krise
irgendwie neuer begriff
es erzeugt natürlich irgendwie schon
klar wirklichkeit also mit sät der wird
bis gemacht mit dem bestimmter gehalten
und ich glaube das ist natürlich genau
die hauptsächlich die wirklich dass in
gronau dabei um mit möglichst wenig
aufwand möglichst große blase um den
investoren zeigt ja wohl darauf der
beste motor härter verbessern
das was sie transportieren wollen sind
wie eben fairness disziplin mentale
kraft entwickeln
durchhaltevermögen teamgeist also all
das was alte kulturen auf eine andere
art und weise versucht haben zu
etablieren werden wir nur interpretieren
und in europa quasi in dieser
kampfsportart mit einbringen
nachdem gerd eder die 150000 euro in die
schweiz überwiesen hatte hörte er
verdächtig lange nichts mehr
jeder suchte informationen im internet
was mich komplett aus der fassung
brachte war ich gebe den namen ein und
sofort kommen negative dinge und zwar
nur negative dinge
es gab nicht einen hinweis dass er
weiter ein guter minister
das ist überall das wort betrug war
sofort in jedem forum und dann weiß ich
dass ich schon sehr sehr erstaunt sehr
erstaunt gt der medien verlust nicht
nehmen der recherchiert tage lang findet
andere anleger die geld verloren haben
er reist in die schweiz sucht käfer
vergeblich er sucht hilfe bei den
behörden und erstattet anzeige in der
schweiz
die telefonverkäufer machen unverdrossen
weiter kritischen kunden sagen sie sie
hätten renommierte wirtschaftsprüfer
verpflichtet zum beispiel
pricewaterhousecoopers pwc eine lüge
pricewaterhousecoopers hat nie für max
gearbeitet dass mit dem preis wozu
heraus dass sich eben mexiko derzeit
überhaupt mit ems tour körpers in yeni
logo irgendwelche kraft spricht dagegen
wurde der börsekurs formaxx unter nun
daraus ein genie logos dazu kopiert
wurde werden dass es so war die kirche
sei irgendwie dazu fest also worauf tot
der sportler ist er nicht hat ein jahr
nach der gründung von max entertainment
zerplatzt sein lebenstraum
der hochgelobte financier käfer taucht
nur noch selten auf
trotzdem bedient er sich mit auffallend
viel bargeld aus der firmenkasse sonst
herrscht flaute
nach dem auftritt im sportfernsehen
entwickelt die firma keine operative
tätigkeit mehr nur der aktienverkauf
läuft hartnäckig weiter
endlich schöpft die finanzmarktaufsicht
verdacht mit einer verfügung verhängt
sie den konkurs über die max
entertainment und weitere firmen die max
aktien verkauft haben
grund unerlaubter aktienhandel zu spät
von 50 millionen franken stellen die
behörden nur noch lumpige 90000 franken
sicher
[Musik]
schwierigkeiten generell wieder
justizverfahren ist das würde meiner
meinung nach falsch vor gott und zwar
eine vor der ersten tat wer immer
vermittler wo sind vermögen sein dass
man den grund clark damals sämtliche
vermögenswert wo irgendwie ohne sind wo
irgendwie raus deine quellen stamme dass
man die air motor prophylaktisch ich
früher
es ist leider häufig wegen so dass wenn
viel strom oder intervenieren das denn
in deiner firmen wahnsinniger dome sind
und viele kunden schmerzhaften verlust
erleidet dass das ist so es ist stromae
so wählt finger und als strafbehörde
könne agiere
wenn sie lewis haben das spin off firma
nicht so läuft wie ursprünglich
vorgesehen das galt und im keine bezogen
war die zinsen gezahlt werden
irgendwelche angreifer sprachige wahr
gemacht worden sind nichtig alt werde
denn was er tun denn nervös und können
wir eben auf die entsprechende behörde
zu unterhalten das denn gottes hilfe
sehr schnell dass mir intervenieren
aber dennis geld häufig lieber unter
sich die kanal ins ausland abgewandert
und kann nun vor vor vor vor der behörde
zurückgeholt werde es resultiert der
verlust also durch sechs behörde hält
die noch wenig licht proaktiv afrika wo
marktmissbrauch sind und das ist ein
relativ einfache geschichte
eine überwachte geht's richtung also mit
see die verschiedenen internet foren etc
tränen ausbricht bestätige vor den
medien also es wird denn es auch nicht
noch in ihrem internet flächendeckend
der mann observiert haben die
möglichkeit nicht haben
der auftrag nicht haben mit ressourcen
ex-coach zu deren kultur wo die für die
bankenkommission und die hütte gefallen
war immer nur am ende das man lang
wartet vielleicht geht es am aller
briefe zwar nicht aber mit hexe
unzählige fall dass täglich reagiert
hätte es irgendwo schlagzeile hacker
irgendeiner ecke oder
konsumentenzeitschrift bis politisch
wurde nicht immer aktiv wurde vielfach
sport will natürlich das
verschleierungsmittel trete sie
angewendet wurde
es ehrt uns unsere spezialisten sei dass
sie oft und fehlender fall nicht
schneller oder mehr machen aber man muss
einfach ausgangslage ist firma wie fair
betrachten das muss ganz langsam wie
hans mitterer ungeheure flut vor hévíz
zu ruf als ewiger illegale tätigkeit zu
priorisieren man kann ja nicht alles
laufen springen und verzeiht man sich
und mir hans mit relativ engen grenzen
seiner wo mehr können tiere und sehr
viel fall wo mir um mir war nahm als und
wo mehr ausgeführt denn der läuft nicht
richtig
die sind aber nicht in unserem ruf sich
zum bereich das sind allenfalls
betrügerisch statik oder und das falle
in andere in andere
hoheitsbereich romy keine augen bei max
entertainment hat die justizbehörde zug
vier jahre lang ermittelt doch eine
staatsanwältin stellte das verfahren ein
von der kamera wollte sie nicht sagen
ihre begründung für die einstellung für
eine anklage wegen betruges hätten die
erkenntnisse nicht gereicht
da sieht das verhalten der beschuldigten
aus meiner sicht nicht unter den
tatbestand des betruges subsumieren
lässt und täuschungshandlungen konnten
mithin nicht nachgelesen werden
eine fehleinschätzung die aktienverkäufe
haben ihre kunden mehrfach belohnt
die dds gerade die karten bewerben
berichtet dauert natürlich ein paar
monate und die frage kann das bedeutet
dass im grund nur hertha vergab so lucy
ohne beute für die staatsanwaltschaft
zog für sie die tätigkeit wissen sie
wenn ich dann einen brief dieser krieg
von der behörde zuvor mitgeteilt wird
es hat mich mal in meinen worten wir
sind selbst schuld dass wir das geld
angelegt haben und ihm und dem jemand
wäre das schlecht nachzuweisen
dann weiß ich nicht nach welchen
ermittlungs komponente diese behörden
vorgehen
das ist für mich einfach ein fass ohne
boden eine unglaublichkeit die ich nur
so ausdrücken kann
und ich versuche es auch nicht zum
bleiben das ist ja so eine situation
anrufer league wenigen ohmacht situation
gegen die chance per gesetz nicht
richtig trainer was eigentlich verrückt
ist bis heute krimineller lüth und das
tut weh für die betroffenen ist das eine
düstere situation
hunderte opfer haben ihr geld verloren
weil ein notorischer schwindler nicht
gestoppt wurde der betrug scheint ihnen
offensichtlich doch es geschieht nichts
rechtliches problem es wird bestimmt vom
betrug wird verlangt dass täter
sogenannte richtig handelt das heißt auf
der andere sieht das opfer vom opfer
verlangt dass es gewisse
sicherheitsdispositiv oft dass es
langsam ist also so post das problem die
georgische zweite problem sind dies
bewies barkeit fordert eine konkrete tat
man muss sie das sind sehr schlaue leute
da am werk sind und die surf natürlich
entlang der strafbarkeit ganze
gewissermaßen zum date ebenso im
dunstkreis vom tatbestand von betrug ein
händler
ich glaube aber dass die schweizer
strafverfolgungsbehörden geht wirklich
zu wenig biss sind und wenig den fallen
zwei vernagelt und ich glaube das geht
aus auch dann nicht durchgesetzt werden
könnte durchsetzt werden
ich habe immer gehofft dass einen jemand
aus der behörde zu mich vorrätig war die
heute noch darauf dass mich die
polizeibehörden das mich sonst wär
vorlegt aber ich bin für jede aussage
bereit ich kann alles belegen was mich
und meinen fall betrifft aber ist will
wahrscheinlich keiner hören ich habe das
gefühl das ist fast schon lästig das ist
eine aussage machen würde
das ist für einen rechtsstaat
doch eine sehr dubiose linie
aus dem netz so dass niemand die
reststoffe dort sowohl mir als sein
kollege in den anderen konten haben
bereits mehrfach und erfolgreich so
verfahren gericht braucht aber es wird
immer schwieriger
somit komme mir vor wie ein virus immer
wenn man meint mein heiliges mittel
dagegen gefunden
dann können sie sich nicht für andere
und neue schaden anrichten
die kollegen des staatsanwaltes in den
nachbarländern können konsequent dagegen
schwindler vorgehen also sich so dass in
deutschland im tatbestand von betrug
über die orgel störte nicht verlangt
wird das geschieht also war nicht durch
schick vorliegt dass man natürlich habe
wie sie wolle durch schick vorliegt dann
steht da bestand erfüllt um dem hammer
viel mehr aber natürlich erfasst vom
strafrecht also mini erfahrung ich so
dass sofern in deutschland regelmäßig zu
früh teilige führen ich habe sogar
persönlich den druck dass einzelne
finanzbetrüger absichtlich getötet indem
sich zum entsprochen hätte das behörde
für eine verurteilung sehr viel hören
ist eine möglichkeit wäre dass man ein
zusätzlicher betrugstatbestand führt ist
drauf salzburg wo die art ist nicht
erforderlich ist
[Musik]
niemand weiß so recht wo sich irgendwo
fällt
wer viele leute über den tisch gezogen
hat gibt seine adresse nicht preis
ein insider vermutet tiefer residiere
immer noch hier lachen am oberen
zürichsee doch käfer ist bereits wieder
ausgezogen
[Musik]
spuren finden sich in der
nordwestschweiz
dort flog im märz 2012 der ase skandal
auf einer der grössten schweizer
geldanlage schwindel der letzten jahre
heute ein jahr später ist das ausmaß des
schadens noch immer nicht definitiv
bekannt
jürgen käfer ist darin verstrickt der
chef der finanzgesellschaft ase im
aargauischen frick investiert
kundengelder in einen dubiosen fonds die
sache geht schief 200 millionen franken
kundengelder verschwinden betroffen sind
ein paar hundert geschädigte zu den
opfern gehören diverse banken und
seriöse anlagefirmen da se chef sitzt in
untersuchungshaft
die hse wurde geschlossen wieder gerät
die aufsichtsbehörde finma in die kritik
[Musik]
das finanzchaos hat eine einschlägige
vorgeschichte der chef der ase hat schon
im jahr 2006 privat große beträge in max
aktien investiert
[Musik]
dies belegt eine kundenliste von max
entertainment kurz danach stand der ase
chef jürgen käfer sogar zusammen und
organisiert den dubiosen kauf einer
inaktiven praktisch wertlosen firma im
fernen kanada
so steht es in einem internen bericht
der finma die firma wusste oder seit
jahren dass sich der asienchef hier
investor genannt im dubiosen umfeld von
käfer tummelte
die neuen geschäftspartner präsentieren
die kanadische firma den max aktionären
als retterin sie sollen ihre inzwischen
wertlosen max aktien eintauschen gegen
die vermeintlich wertvollen aktien der
kanadischen firma natürlich gegen
aufpreis die unrühmliche vergangenheit
des chefs war der finma seit 2007
bekannt gehandelt hat sie nicht heutige
sicht ist es sehr sehr schwer
nachvollziehen dass aufsichtsbehörde
damals nicht der dass auch nachgegangen
ist
die sachverhalte genau kennt und die
geldflüsse kind hand protagonisten
namentlich kennt und das ist nie
passiert wenn du 60 hörte damals richtig
vorgang wäre hätte die das desaster rund
um die ase investment ag eine verhindert
werde
wo vermutlich basler kantonalbank carney
dass das aus trikot wer wie sich das
noch überhaupt zeichnet die hand im fall
als schlicht kein whiskey bis 2012 dass
da irgend reform gegen finanzmarkt
gesetz verstoßen wo dem herrn zu spüren
dass ich ein ganz wichtiger indikator
für uns wäre kein einziger kunde
reaktion kam neben sky einzige grund wo
wir uns auch bitterkeit und seither
bestimmt nicht ich krieg der mini zinsen
nicht ich kann
geld nimmt ein bisschen darin out und
viessmann einzige kunde reaktion kam
zwischen 2007 und 2012 mehr jedes
schweiz im vergleich zu anderen ländern
als schwacher kundenschutz mit helmi
banker schutz als kundenschutz oder mehr
vermögensverwalter schutz als
kundenschutz dass ich eines historisch
bedingt vom gesetzgeber her und das ist
aber andererseits auch durch die sehr
starke schon kultur
frühere genetische banga kommission
bedingt und das zusammen führt dazu dass
die österreicher schlacht schützt dich
[Musik]
wann brauchen bürgerschutz
wo beginnt die selbstverantwortung wie
weit da vertrauen gehen und soll der
staat dieses vertrauen in der
gesellschaft schützen
schwindler handeln außerhalb
gesellschaftliche regeln
vor zwei monaten hatte doch von finanz
wendler irgend käfer eine zusage zu dem
interview erhalten
danach blieben weitere mails allerdings
unbeantwortet
im zürcherischen wald bei wittstock
jürgen käfer mit frau karin beim
betanken ihres bentleys seit 20 jahren
ist der mann in dubiose geschäfte
verwickelt
deswegen verurteilt wurde er bisher nie
seinen lebensstandard finanzieren und
freiwillig hunderte von opfern
heikel situation ist er gewohnt
äußerlich lässt sich der profi nicht aus
der ruhe bringen
aus juristischen gründen darf doch die
szene nicht vollständig zeigen
im anschließenden gespräch zeigt sich
käfer charmant will ich sogar zu einem
interview ein stattgefunden hat es
allerdings nie inzwischen hat ein
gericht entschieden dass hinzog das
verfahren gegen käfer wieder aufgenommen
werden muss tiefer bei uns nicht zu
kümmern
außerdem verfasste bezeugt dass zucker
kollegen das verfahren korrekt werden zu
entführen
allerdings ist zeigen dass bis der fall
am landgericht ist unschuldsvermutung
gilt und dass highstreet bis neues
iphone und meistens fange wieder töpfer
sondern sie machen das was sie immer
gemacht hat
es hätten je nach der hand habe auch
meine unschuldige biete ein bisschen
häuser erzwungen
er wird mit sicherheit noch viel viel
mehr menschen täuschen ja schon viele
menschen getäuscht
und er ist ich sage es mal so fast schon
gewohnt dass behörden dem treiben
zusehen und eigentlich wird das hier
gefördert dieser mann wird ja eigentlich
gefördert obwohl eigentlich zu einer
verurteilung schon längst fällig gewesen
wäre
adliswil am zürichsee neues domizil
einer firma namens sense energy die
firma ist auf karin käfer eingetragen
jürgen käfer und den sohn sind ins
geschäft involviert
hier kann man in grüne energie
investieren
bambus der verdacht eine weitere
luftnummer aus dem hause kefer
zwischendurch haben nachbarn reges
telefonieren wahrgenommen
allein die käfer sind bereits wieder
weitergezogen
[Musik]
wir müssen diesen menschen einheit
gebieten müssten die leute verhören die
leute ist eigentlich holen müsste
verhören müssen aussagen der fall muss
geprüft werden
es kann nicht angehen dass eine ebk oder
eine firma wie sie heute als tatenlos
zusehen das kann jeden normal denken und
fühlen menschen wirklich zur weißglut
bringen
[Musik]
ja also bei fast zwei jahre lang jeden
morgen auf standen bereit
und schlagen dann hab ich überhaupt
nicht irgendwie rachen aber ich hasse
das los eigentlich aufgabe
warum wissen wir auch ganz leicht
gegangen ich mich zwei jahre weg nach
ganz ganz ganz leicht gegangen nur
finanziell und mit dem ass zweiter
moralisch was an items zu bekommen und
dann wachse dass es für mich sei aber
sehr gesundes und das eigene schloss
handel bringt
[Musik]
und das heißt für mich dass wir mit dem
geld lieber andere sachen schöner ist
auch macht eine familie sport und das
geld
jetzt denkt dass die ganze familie darin
liegt die wirkliche leben ist damit du
um vor und rufen kaum sport bewegt aber
natürlich dass ich relativ wenig wein
mit einer schlacht der urfeld dass er
schon katastrophen aber das braucht er
auch jahrelang herzogenrath stellen
es wird einfach kein ende nehmen wenn
nicht jetzt irgendwas passiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]